look the Internet's a wild place it's
giving you [ __ ] on Twitter I give you
the motor oil of thing I was like I love
you
look we could talk we can talk about it
you ready so so the context yeah so pump
so let me give you my reaction this is
great we're gonna like everyone loves
tension I do I did [ __ ] I also go go
okay so this I think was like March
right so Dennis Loyola issued its own
cryptocurrency called your petrol that
was gonna be backed by its petroleum
reserves right and I like to call them
hunger tokens yeah it's terrible it's a
bad situation but you have a legitimate
reason for describing it that way
yes but but I think what troubled me is
pumping out this tweet and you were like
mister tokenized the world spread the
virus which I love write these messages
but I do think it like they rile up
spread the virus sounds WAY worse than
the virus is spreading pump it out this
tweet that said the virus is spreading
like I look at everyone adopting
blockchain and tokenization best example
yet Venezuela creating the petrol and
what you said actually was true but it
was a terrible example yep and I think
again it goes back to like there are
things that are correct technically and
then there are things that are correct
morally my objection wasn't on the
correctness of the statement her factual
perspective it was the fact that you had
a really big audience and this statement
from like a moral and subjective
perspective was just it felt like
implicit endorsement of something that
was subjectively horrific absolutely
yeah and I think that you know when you
said when you put it in that light first
it was hey I didn't think that me saying
this obviously is me endorsing the
Venezuelan government right and so but
but but I think part of it too is and
this is only that you know look I think
we struggle with a lot internally we
talk about when you're in an area where
experimentation is very important
right there's going to be people who try
things that cross the line or push to an
edge that you don't agree with right now
where's that moral line etc and so it's
how do you encourage experimentation how
do you speak out against the bad
applications of the technology that's
like an expression of there are no
sacred cows right like there maybe we
should be able to experiment with
anything and everything even if it
pushes the boundaries of what currently
is socially accepted what was I think
that I think the thing that we struggle
with is well here's the thing that we
struggle with is so there are probably
sacred cows right what if we actually
don't understand everything well enough
yet to know where those sacred cows are
well we don't know anything right that's
it really the crux of this conversation
is actually I know nothing all I know is
that I need to ask better questions and
so and then I need specificity so people
make statements like oh are protocols
decentralized I specify what
decentralized means think better
questions and like let's accept I agree
with that we don't we don't know what we
don't know